hello everyone and welcome to the excel
exhibition center here in London home to
the ftth conference 2013 the 10th
edition in fact of the ftth conference
and boy are we happy to be here now
tomorrow is the official opening of the
conference however it's fair to say
there's quite a lot going on in there
today so I'm going to give you a little
sneak preview now there's a huge amount
of people in there all preparing
everything for tomorrow's conference so
come with me I can guarantee that no one
in their slacking okay it's now
you
now I could spend the rest of the
afternoon showing you all the exhibition
stands and all the hard work that's
indeed going on in there however that
would be missing out one vital
ingredient for today which are the
workshops in fact the sessions are
happening as we speak now some of the
themes that we'll be looking at today
are FTTH in the UK smart cities
technology innovations and we'll also be
looking at some of the investors who
wish to invest in FTTH networks in fact
the workshops today have been put
together by the ftth counseled europe so
let's have a look
hi Chris now what are the challenges for
the ftth rollout in the UK well we
believe the government's Broadband Plan
is not sufficiently ambitious it favors
one provider which is the incumbent BTW
and they made a technology choice which
is fiber to the curve not
fibre-to-the-home UK citizens and
generally not well-informed so they
don't really fit and there's only a
handful of five to the home projects in
the UK which is one of the reasons why
the UK still only has one percent of
households with 52 though I'm joined now
by Thomas from the ftth Council Europe
now Thomas is it true there is money
available to finance the ftth projects
yes indeed actually there are lots of
people around here and we know that very
many people look at future proof
infrastructure projects the thing is
though that government regulators and
project sponsors have to find ways to
mitigate demand risk and that is the
objective of the investor day at the
ftth conference
I'm joined now by Paolo from the ftth
Council Europe now Paolo what is a smart
city a smart city is based on a
comprehensive integrated approach which
is needed to increase the efficiency the
productivity the ecological awareness of
the citizens and it will reduce the
pollution and improve the quality of
life you can compare the city with a
living organism the city can for
instance adapt automatically to several
circumstances and the network is built
the superfast nervous system for for the
city which allows the city to to take
action thank you very much power
so here we are it's the end of day one
here at the excel exhibition center here
in London as you can see everything here
is now empty you could hear a pin drop
which means that tomorrow is the
official opening of the ftth conference
here in London 2013 now tomorrow when
you join us there's going to be some
inspiration innovation there's going to
be a little bit of information and some
xhilaration which means in brief is
going to be beyond belief
you